[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء شنت قوات تحالف
دعم الشرعيه في اليمن ليله السبت اكثر من
100 غاره على مواقع الحوثيين ردا على
قصفهم مواقع بجنوب المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وذلك بعد ساعات من اعلان الرياض
هدنه انسانيه تبدا يوم الثلاثاء المقبل
وتستمر خمسه ايام بشرط التزام الحوثيين
بتطبيقها نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين ما دلالت عوده قوات التحالف دعم
الشرعيه في اليمن الى تكثيف غاراتها ضد
الحوثيين بهذا
المستوى وكيف سينعكس تكثف غارات التحالف
ضد الحوثيين على موقف هؤلاء من الهدنه
الانسانيه
المقترحه اذا في اعقاب قصف نفذه الحوثيون
على مواقع في جنوب المملكه العربيه
السعوديه شنت قوات التحالف ليله الجمعه
السبت 100 غاره على الاقل ضد اهداف
للحوثيين في صعده وحجه شمالي اليمن طائرات
التحالف وصلت غارتها صباح السبت على اهداف
بالعاصمه صنعاء في سياق غارات اعتبرت
الاعنف منذ بدء عملياتها ضد الحوثيين
وقوات الرئيس المخلوع علي عبد الله صالح
قبل نحو شهر
ونصف نسق جديد للحمله العسكريه الجويه ضد
الحوثيين في اليمن هذه المره المحور صعد
شمالا معقل جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين وهي
لشدتها كانت الاعنف منذ بدء العمليات
العسكريه اواخر مارس اذار الماضي حتى لكها
تبدو عاصفه اشد حزما عقابا للجماعه على
قصفها مناطق سعوديه حدوديه وسقوط قتلى
وجرحى فما ان انتهت مهله التحالف لاهالي
المدينه لمغادرتها حتى انهالت القنابل
والصواريخ على مقرات ومراكز اتصالات
ومخازن اسلحه تابعه للحوثيين في مناطق
متفرقه من المحافظه الحدوديه مع يه منها
الطلح والمنزله والكنب ومران وبني معاذ
وغيرها كما استهدفت الغارات مقرات قيادات
كبيره في الجماعه بينها مقار زعيمها عبد
الملك الحوثي في مناطق ضحيان وجبل التيس
ومديريه
مجز وتحمل هذه الحمله المكثفه عده رسائل
الى الحوثيين اساسا لعل اهمها الردع وهو
ان اي استهداف للسعوديه سيكون ثمنه باهظا
ولن يكتفى بالرد عليه حدوديا بل ايضا في
العمق ثم ان تدفع صعد الجانب الاكبر من
ذلك الثمن قد يدخل ايضا ضمن الحرب النفسيه
والمعنويه على الجماعه نظرا للقيمه
الرمزيه العاليه التي توليها ل صعده وهي
قيمه يتقاطع فيها التاريخي بالمذهب لكن
الاهم من كل ذلك ربما بالنسبه لتحالف هو
فرض الهدنه المقترحه لمده خمسه ايام
ابتداء من يوم الثلاثاء المقبل الثاني عشر
من ايار مايو الحالي هدنه تبدو ضروريه في
ضوء تدهور الوضع الانساني لالاف الاسر لكن
قد يرفضها الحوثيون او قد يستغلونها
لاعاده ترتيب اوضاعهم العسكريه اذا كان ما
زال لديهم ما يكفي من القدرات العسكريه
وهذا ما نبهت اليه الرياض التي اكدت ان
الهدنه ستنتهي في حال عدم التزام الحوثيين
بها او في حال محاولتهم الاستفاده منها
عسكريا غير ان تصدر صعد بنك اهداف التحالف
لم يعني ابدا هدوء فيما سواها من اليمن
طائره التحالف قصفت مقر اللواء العاشر
دفاع جوي شرق قاعده الديلم الجويه في
صنعاء وذلك بموازاه اشتباكات عنيفه خاضتها
المق مه الشعبيه مع الحوثيين وقوات الرئيس
المخلوع في الضالع وتعز وشبوه وعدن بينما
امهلت المقاومه الشعبيه بمحافظه مارب
المسلحين الحوثيين وحلفائهم حتى عصر الاحد
للانسحاب غير المشروط من المحافظه والا
اخرجتهم
بالقوه موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيوفنا هنا
في الاستديو الدكتور عبد الله الحاضري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اليمني ومن
الرياض الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
السعودي العميد حسن الشهري ومن صنعاء عبر
الهاتف عبد الوهاب الشرفي الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي وابدا من الرياض مع السيد حسن
الشهري سيد حسن هل تكثيف الغارات هو رد
على ما تعرضت له مناطق حدوديه سعوديه فقط
ام له اهداف عسكريه اخرى في هذه
المرحله بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله
والصلاه سلام على رسول الله شكرا
للاستضافه تحيه لك وزملاء المشاركين اود
التاكيد على انه استراتيجيه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه الوطنيه تستهدف السلم
كمبدا وه هدفها في السلم هو
الامن قبل كل شيء ثم الرخاء بالاضافه الى
انه في هذه المرحله دول التحالف تطبق
الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه لتحقيق الاهداف ام
والاهداف تعمل لتحقيق المصالح الوطنيه ما
يخص
السؤال عمليه ما يسمى ثار نجران وجيزان في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه قامت
هذه العمليه منذ يومين لهدفين الهدف الاول
هو دعم اهداف مرحله اعاده الامل وهي واضحه
للجميع واعيدت اكثر من مره الهدف الثاني
هو منع
قوات الحوثيين وعلي عبد الله صالح بل
دحرهم لانه اذا ما تم اجبارهم على ايقاف
عملياتهم
الارهابيه فلن يوافقوا لا على هدنه وليس
في يدهم قراء القرار ياتي من طهران فاذا
صدر من طهران القرار لدينا فرصه الى
الساعه 11 مساء يوم الثلاثاء اذا استطاعت
امريكا والدول المؤثره على ايران ان ان
تؤثر في ايران بحيث انها تصدر اوامرها
لعبد الملك الحوثي ولعبد الله علي عبد
الله صالح بان يقبل الهدنه قد ت تتنفذ
الهدنه و سي الشه نعم سيدي الشهري افهم
منك بانه تكثيف الغرات هو
لهدفين الهدف الاول يتعلق
بالثار والانتقام لما حصل لنجران وجيزان
والهدف الثاني هو الضغط لقبول الحث
بالهدنيا عبد الوهاب الشرفي الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي سيد عبد الوهاب الى اي
مدى يمكن ان تربك وتؤثر هذه الغارات
المكثفه بدءا من ليله الجمعه السبت على
العمل العسكري وعلى تحرك الحوثيين وهم
يتعرضون لهذه الغارات في عقر دارهم في
صعدا بدايه مساء الخير لك ولضيوفك الكرام
وساده المشاهدين
الاكارم الحقيقه ان تكثف الغارات بهذا
المستوى هو
ربما لن يكون مؤثرا بالقدر المطلوب اساسا
على تحرك وقياده انصار الله على اعتبار
انه المسائل ربما اغلبها هي في جبهات
التقاتل وليست في مدينه صعدا التي الان
يتم التصعيد
باتجاهها اعتبار مدينه صعدا كامل هدف
عسكري هذا الامر هو ربما الهدف فيه قضيه
الضغط على انصار الله عن طريق استهداف
جمهورهم وا من المدنيين اما قضيه التاثير
العسكري يظل محدودا للغايه لن يؤتي سماره
على الاطلاق يعني ام ولكن يعني حسب ما
تؤكد قياده التحالف فان ما يقصف حاليا في
صعده هو مراكز الاتصالات هو مخازن اسلحه و
ذخيره وايضا مراكز قياديه للحوثيين وعندما
تصاب هذه المراكز من الطبيعي ان يكون هناك
تاثير ما خصوصا وان قياده القرار موجوده
في
صعدا يا سيدي الكريم ليس هناك بنيه عسكريه
اساسا في صعدا بالنسبه لانصار الله بالشكل
الذي يعني
يتصوره يعني بنيه الدوله في الاخير هم
جماعه هذه الجماعه لها بناه محدوده وطبيعه
قعدا ايضا لا يمكن يعني ليس فيها المباني
الشاهقه او الشوارع الطويله العريضه في
الاخير صعده هي مدينه صغيره اغلب مبانيها
هي من الطين وبالتالي الحديث عن مراكز
سيطره والحديث عن اهداف عسكريه هو ربما في
الاخير هو محدود للغايه جدا في صعده قياده
انصار الله هم خارج صعده الان بالتاكيد
باعتبار ان هناك اكثر من جبهه مشتعله
وقواعد اللعبه اصبحت متعلقه بهذه الجبهات
اكثر من
من تعلقها بصعده يعني قضيه مثلا السيطره
على عدن اصبحت نقطه من نقاط ما يحسب عليه
التقدم او التقهقر لاي من الطرفين
وبالتالي التركيز هو سيكون هناك وليس في
صعدا في الاخير توقعي انا انه سيكون
محدودا اكثر من سيتضرر هم المدنيين
وبالامس كان هناك حاله نزوح كبيره جدا من
صعدا الناس في اوضاع انسانيه ماساويه طيب
دكتور عبد الله الحضري يعني استمعت الى
السيد حسن الشهري وهو يتحدث عن ان واحده
من اهداف تكثيف الغارات هو دعم اهداف
مرحله اعاده الامل كيف تقرا ما يحصل الان
في سياق العمليه العسكريه برمتها اولا
ينبغي التطرق الى عاصفه الحزم واستراتيجيه
عاصفه الحزم حتى نربطها باستراتيجيه اعاده
الامل او الامل استهدفت عاصفه الحزب
القضاء على الاشياء القضاء على الوسائد
الماديه العسكريه القضاء على الامكانيات
الماديه كانت لعلي عبد الله صالح
والحوثيين قض على صواريخ سكوت على الطيران
وحققت اهدافها لكن وجدت قياده ال التحالف
انه لم يؤثر هذا على الواقع العملياتي على
الارض الحوثيين يتقدمون باحترافيه ومهنيه
ويحققوا مكاسب اذا ما كانت تصبو اليه
الاستراتيجيه العسكريه من تحقيق اهداف
ماديه او ضرب البنى الماديه حتى يتوقف
العمليات العسكريه العرض لم تتحقق بالكامل
توقفت عاصفه الحزب واتجهوا بعد ذلك الى
اعاده الامل لكنهم قرروا هذه المره المسير
ناحيه الاشخاص لانه اكتشفوا في الاخير او
تبادر الى اذهانهم انه الحوثيين والقوه
المتحالفه معهم لا ترتكز على الوسائد
الماديه بقدر ما ترتكز على الانسان على
البشر يعني النظريه العسكريه الغربيه التي
تعتنقها دول التحالف كثافه نيران مقابل
قله في الامكانيات البشريه او استخدام
البشر لكن بالنسبه للقوى الموجوده اليمن
الامر معكوس تماما يعتمدون على الانسان
ولا يركزون على الكثافه النيراني ولا على
الوسائد الماديه وبالتالي بداوا يستهدفون
الان الانسان الاشخاص ولا يركزون على
البنيه التحتيه ولا يركزون على الكثافه
الايرانيه لانه اصلا غير موجوده لا من حيث
التصنيع ولا من حيث الوجود الان بعد ان تم
ضربها في عاصفه الحزم الان في تغير
استراتيجي بناء على المتغيرات على الارض
خاصه بعد ضرب نجران اكتشفوا انه الاهداف
التي كان يصب اليها ليست حقيقيه لم تؤثر
على الميدان العملياتي لم تقلل من حجم
المخاطر التي كان يتوقع ان يوقفوها لان
الحوثيون وحلفائهم يرتكزون على الاحترافيه
يدربون الانسان ويركزون عليه في وجودهم
على المستوى العملياتي وعلى المستوى
الاستراتيجي طيب اعود لك سيد حسن الشهري
ضيفنا من صنعاء اعتبر بانه تكثف الغارات
قد لا يؤدي الهدف المطلوب لان الحوثيين
قاده الحوثيين هم خارج صعده وصعده ليس
فيها تلك الاهداف الكبيره التي يمكن ان
تؤثر في سير المعركه ما
رايك قد اتفق في جزئيه واختلف في جزئيات
اولا لا نود ان نمي الموضوع بهذه الطريقه
وانا اقدر اقدر ماذا ينوي او يد قوله لكن
استهداف المراكز التي تصدر منها الاوامر
من صعده الى الحدود السعوديه ومن صعده الى
المليشيات الارهابيه للحوثيين وجيش صالح
في جميع مناطق اليمن هي في صعده وبالتالي
اذا ع الراس عن الجسد تاثر او مات بقيه
الاطراف
العمليات التحالف في في هذه المرحله
وبالتالي امس وهذه الليله سيكون لها تاثير
وواقع مباشر
و قوي على الارض ننتظر فقط التاثير الدولي
ام السعوديه ودول التحالف ليست دول راغبه
في الحرب ولكنها دول استجابت ل
سيدي الشهري هنا يطرح سؤال يعني على اهميه
هذه الاهداف التي تقصف يطرح سؤال اساسي
لماذا تركت هذه الاهداف الى ما بعد حوالي
شهر ونصف من بدء عاصفه الحزم ولم يقطع
الراس منذ
البدايه انا احد الاشخاص على التلفزيون في
يوم من الايام اكدت على انه يجب استهداف
عبد الملك الحوثي وعلي عبد الله صالح
واقول بدون واربه لانهم هم هم المؤثرين
على الساحه اليمنيه افعى
براسين لدول التحالف تقدير يعملوا من خلال
خطط استراتيجيه المنطقه ليست بمعزل عن
العالم تتاثر دول التحالف بغيرها وتؤثر
فيها و وضعوا بعض او تلك الخطه حتى يصلوا
الى مرحله يقضوا فيها على الاسلحه القويه
والمؤثره على دول الجوار وعلى الشعب
اليمني ندرك ان الحوثيين من سنوات طويله
وهم وضعوا من اليمن عن طريق ايران مستودع
كبير جدا للاسلحه والاسلحه الخفيفه
والمتوسطه السهل اخفائها والسهل التنقل
فيها وانا اؤكد الان على انه كلام زميلنا
عندك في الاستديو ان لولا علي عبد الله
صالح
وجيشه والقبائل المواليه مع الاسف اقولها
بمل فمي في شمال اليمن لم تكن الحاله في
اليمن بهذا السوء ا طيب عمليه ما بعد او
نهايه اعاده الامل حيكون لها اثر ايجابي
ان شاء الله يرى في القريب العاجل طيب
اعود الى ضيفي من صنعاء السيد عبد الوهاب
الشرفي سيد عبد الوهاب ما يجري ما الغارات
المكثفه على صعده و وما تستهدف به من
مقرات قياديه هل تعتقد بانها سترد
الحوثيين على الاقل من التعرض للمناطق
الحدوديه
السعوديه يا سيدي الكريم انا ربما من
البدايه تحدثت حتى هنا على الجزيره ان
اسلوب التعامل مع الازمه الحاصله في اليمن
بالتعامل العسكري اساسا هو اسلوب خاطئ كان
لدينا ازمه قائمه هذه الازمه لو سوء
الاداره السياسيه من من من دول الخارج لما
وصلت المسائل الى ما وصلت اليه الان نحن
امام واقع بطبيعته انت لو تتذكر بدايه
الاحداث التي ذهبت باتجاه نجران هي لم تكن
منطلقه اساسا من قوه انصار الله بقدر ما
كانت منطلقه من مجموعه قرى هذه القرى
اعتقد انا هي التي سيطرت على موقع المناره
في البدايه هذه هي تعرضت لقذائف الى كراها
و ردت ومن هنا بدا الاشتعال في نجران الذي
اقصده انا ان ان يعني اعتماد اسلوب
العسكري لحل الازمه في اليمن هو سيفات
الامور بشكل اكبر الضحايا ممن ربما حاليا
هم يجتنبون التدخل نتيجه ما يحصل وما سيصل
لهم و اس على كل في مقابل العمل العسكري
في مقابل العمل العسكري المطروح بدءا من
يوم الثلاثاء المقبل هدنه غير معروف اذا
كانت هذه الهدنه ستوضع موضع التنفيذ ام لا
بحسب الشروط وبحسب استجابه الحثيين وغير
ذلك هذا مشاهدينا ما سنناقشه بعد الفاصل
سنناقش الهدنه تاثير تكثيف الغارات على
امكانيه نجاح الهدنه ابقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا في هذه
هذه الحلقه التي تناقش تكثيف دول التحالف
غارتها على مواقع الحوثيين وتاثير ذلك على
موقف هؤلاء من الهدنه الانسانيه المقترحه
في اليمن اعود الى ضيفي في الاستوديو
الدكتور عبد الله الحاضري دكتور عبد الله
هل تعتقد بان تكثيف الغرات يمكن ان يدفع
الحوثيين في نهايه المطاف الى القبول
بالهدنيا على اعتبار انه هناك ازمه
انسانيه اصبحت موجوده وانه ايضا قد يكونون
في وضع عسكري صعب يفرض عليهم القبول
بهدنيه الاستراتيجي الكامل من هذه العمليه
العسكريه برمتها هو عوده الشرعيه ومن ثم
الخضوع لقرار مجلس الامن الدولي رقم 22 16
هذا هو الهدف الاستراتيجي العام اعتقد انه
تقرير الهدنه والالتزام بها تمهيدا لتنفيذ
هذا القرار يعني اذا التزمت الاطراف
بالهدنيا سيكون تمهيدا لتنفيذ قرارات مجلس
الامن الدولي ستعطي فرصه للجميع لكي
يعودوا الى خاصه هذا من حيث المبدا لكن هل
تعتقد انه يمكن ان ان يتحقق ذلك انا اعتقد
انه الوضع الانساني الوضع الكارثي التي في
اليمن تحتم على كل من لديه ادنى مستويات
الاخلاق ان يلتزم بهذه الهدنه الجميع بلا
استثناء واعتقد انه على الحوثيين وعلى علي
عبد الله الصالح ان يلتزم بهذا الهدن وان
يتحملوا مسؤوليتهم التاريخيه امام الله ثم
امام التاريخ ثم امام الشعب اليمني من
يخرق هذه الهدنه في تصوري انه يعمل ضد
مصلحه الشعب اليمني ويعمل ضد حقوق الانسان
ويعمل ضد المباد الا سي حسن الشهري تكثيف
الغارات قبل ثلاثه ايام من الموعد المقترح
لهذه الهدنه الا
يناقض نوايا الهدنه خصوصا وانها مشروطه
باشتراطات قد تصل الى حد وصفها باستسلام
الحوثيين والقوات المواليه للرئيس المخلوع
علي عبد الله
صالح اولا لو نتذكر الاهداف الاهداف
السياسيه لعاصفه الحزم كلنا يدرك انه من
احم اهداف هذه الحمله هو تجريد علي عبد
الله صالح والحوثيين من الاسلحه المؤثره
على اليمن زميلنا في صنعاء قالوا العمل
العسكري عمل غير مناسب تمدد الحوثيين
وانتقام علي عبد الله صالح لم يقم
بالتقبيل قام باستخدام
القوات المسلحه اليمنيه والميليشيات
الحوثيه للاستيلاء على السلطه وعلى اليمن
بالكامل ولولا الله سبحانه وتعالى ثم
اتخاذ القرار بعاصفه الحزم لكان اليمن هو
الدوله الرابعه الحقيقيه كما تتمنى
الامبراطوريه الفارسيه في طهران مشروع
استهدف ولن يتوقف العمل اذا كانت اذا ك
السعوديه ودول التحالف مع اي قرار من وافق
على الهدنه ومن وضع الهدنه ومن وضع الشروط
هي المملكه العربيه السعوديه ودول التحالف
بفضل الله والمؤمن القوي خير من المؤمن
الضعيف اذا استطاعوا الاخوان في اليمن اذا
كانوا يمنيين اصليين انا ما اعرف عبد
الملك الحوثي هل جده اتى مع الفرس الذي
اتوا قبل مئات السنين لنصره سيف بدي زن
اذا كان يماني ومن اهل البيت وهو حقيقي
كذلك فدماء اليمن محرم عليه ويجب ان يتوقف
والمسلم الخطاء التواب
خير من الذي يستمر في الخطا ولكن اؤكد على
انه العمليه
العسكريه ستستمر وبكثافة
[موسيقى]
ربما على غير الشروط الموضوعيه اساسا
لقيامها على الارض وهذا الكلام تحدثنا فيه
كثيرا انه كان يجب ان يتم في هذه القضيه
التنسيق مع الاطراف في الميدان للحظه
زمنيه معينه يتم التوقف فيها لكن على كل
حال الان هناك دعوه انا لا اتوقع ان
الحوثيين او غير الحوثييين يمكنهم ان
يرفضوا قضيه هدنه انسانيه للتبعات
الاخلاقيه لهذا الرفض نحن لدينا حاله
انسانيه هي ت طلب الان اكثر من هدنه هناك
في عدن هناك في المحافظات الجنوبيه التي
تجري فيها الاشتباكات في صعدا هناك حاله
انسانيه لم تعد يعني قابله للتاخير حتى
ليوم واحد ما بالك وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
ذكر بان هناك عفوا سيدي الشرفي وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي بالامس ذكر ان هناك
مؤشرات تدل على
قبول الحوثيين للهدنه الانسانيه هل تعتقد
انهم يقبلونها بالشروط
الموضوعه انا
يعني ادعو من هنا لان يقبلوا سواء ادعوهم
هم لان يقبلوا وادعو المعنيين في طرف
التحالف لان يدفعوا بالعوامل الموضوعيه
لقيام هذه الهدنه عن طريق التنسيق مع
المتقاتلين في الارض من حيث المبدا قلت لك
انا لا اعتقد ان هناك طرف سيرفض الهدنه
لكن عدم التنسيق على الواقع هو الذي قد
يؤدي الى اجهاض هذه الفرصه التي نريدها
جميعا غافه الناس في عدن وفي لاحج وفي
صعدا وفي المتضررين من المدنيين الذين لا
حول لهم ولا قوه دكتور الحاضري هل من
امكانيه
لنجاح الهدنه المقترحه ابتداء من الثلاثاء
برايك في ظل ما سمعته الان من مواقف انا
متفائل متفائل بان الهدنه ستنجح ان شاء
الله لماذا متفائل لانه ال العقل ومقتضيات
العقل يقتضي هذا الكلام وانه لا يوجد مانع
لا عقلاني ولا شرعي ولا اخلاقي يمنع من
عدم انجاحها الكل الان في اليمن يشعر ان
اليمن على وجه كارثه وانه لا لكن لا احد
يتوقع ان ان يسلم الحوثيين سلاحهم او يعني
يمكن ان يلتزموا بهدنيه لكن الشروط
الموضوعه هي ليس فقط هدنه انسانيه نحن
الان نقول الان نحن على مشارف هدنه
انسانيه اولا ومن ثم اذا [__] نجحت الهدنه
الانسانيه يمكن نتكلم بعد ذلك على كيفيه
وضع قرار مجلس الامن الدولي رق 22 16 موضع
التنفيذ انا اعتقد انه الان الحوثيين
ينبغي ان يراجعوا انفسهم وعلي عبد الله
الص ينبغي ان يراجعوا نفسه وانا اناديهم
جميعا الان اليمن على وش كارثه مصلحه
اليمن ينبغي ان توضع فوق الجميع وينبغي
الان التحول الى العمل السياسي والحوار
حتى نخرج من هذا المازق لن يخرج احد من
هذه الحرب خاصه في الاطراف المتسارعه في
الساحه اليمنيه منتصره لا يوجد نصره كل
خاسر فيها وينبغي الان تحكيم العقل
والمنطق والعوده الى القرارات الدوليه
والعوده الى الاتفاقيات اللي كنا قد
اتفقنا عليها للخروج من هذه ماساه
الانسانيه ال شكرا لك دكتور عبد الله
الحضري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
اليمني واشكر من الرياض الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي السعودي العميد حسن الشهري
ومن صنعاء عبر الهاتف اشكر عبد الوهاب
الشرفي الكاتب والمحلل السياسي بهذا
مشاهدينا تنتهي حلقتنا من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه جديده
فيما وراء خبر جديد الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]
ا